non
fin de partie pour ronald reagan
l'ancien acteur quitte la maison blanche
en pleine gloire demain george bush sera
président la cob poursuit scellant son
enquête dans la sphère pechiney l'étau
se resserre autour de deux ou trois
personnages clé ce sont les fraudeurs
rien ne va plus entre le pc et le ps les
deux partis de gauche se fâche
à propos des municipales les communistes
sont furieux le trouble en pologne
l'éventuelle légalisation de solidarité
provoque plus de remous dans le parti
polonais que chez les opposants
michel debré sous la coupole
l'ancien premier ministre du général de
gaulle a été reçu cet après midi à
l'académie française bonsoir avant de
développer tous ses titres cette bavure
de la justice cela ce passe à reims un
magistrat surchargés de travail laisse
un dossier au fond de son tiroir
résultat un homme inculpé pourtant
d'assassinât et remis en liberté le plus
légalement du monde
dominique verdeilhan enquêter à reims
sur cette bavure qui hélas n'est pas un
cas unique
alain demandre inculpé d'assassinât est
aujourd'hui un homme libre et libre par
erreur le 9 septembre 86 il tue des neuf
balles le mari de la femme dont il était
pris vingt-quatre heures après alain
demande avoue son crime
en septembre dernier deux ans après les
faits l'instruction est close
le parquet dispose alors de deux mois
pour statuer sur le renvoi aux assises
seulement lundi dernier deux mois après
le délai légal
le dossier demande est retrouvé dans une
armoire
c'est un grand sentiment de tristesse de
ma part je suis responsable de ce
parquet
de la part du magistrat qui a commis
cette erreur tout à fait involontaire il
faut bien le dire pour laquelle il n'y a
absolument aucune excuse à chercher
jaune à dos innovantes et à la totale
responsabilité
un oubli fâcheux qui oblige lundi
dernier le parquet remettre deux fils en
liberté à la demande une libération sans
condition sans contrôle judiciaire qui
n'est pas du goût de mme adam booth et
la veuve de la victime n'aurait pas dû
l'oublier comme ça tout nous on appelle
souvent pour savoir que le où on est
qu'on va passer le jugement le procès et
puis bon ben on nous dit d'entre eux
mais semestre 89 on attend on attend on
attend
et puis un beau jour on se rende matin
en apprenant journal que meurtri est
libéré source adhérents complètement des
remplaçants l'instruction n'est pas
remise en cause pour autant
mais alain demande qui risque la
réclusion à perpétuité
sera-t-il présent à son procès demande
c'est tout de même que si on leur prix
n'est coupable il risque une peine très
importante
on va peut-être se dire qu'il n'a rien à
perdre on ne se présentant pas en ce qui
me concerne j'essaierai de le convaincre
de se présenter ce soir alain demandera
promis à son avocat de se présenter
devant la justice le parquet promet de
ne pas quitter des yeux ce dossier trop
vite classé demain aux états unis george
bush va devenir le 41e président serment
investiture et successions une
succession particulièrement difficile
pour monsieur bush car ronald reagan
les sondages le montrent a été le
président américain le plus populaire
depuis la deuxième guerre mondiale
tant et si bien qu'aujourd'hui à
washington pour sa dernière
représentation
l'ancien acteur d'hollywood a bouleversé
toute l'amérique dernier baisser de
rideau plein d'émotions jean-marc il use
mes amis aujourd'hui les mots me
manquent pour vous exprimer ma gratitude
et celle de nancy
merci du fond du coeur qui aux quatre
échelons
les adieux du président reagan suite et
fin ce matin devant le personnel de la
maison blanche
une fois n'est pas coutume celle que les
journalistes surnommé le dragon du
palais nancy reagan à la gorge nouée et
doit renoncer au micro
thank you mais jusqu'au dernier acte les
années reagan le spectacle continue
ronald regan enchaîne top alors
qu'istres pour anne irrésistible ce
n'est qu'un au revoir
je
la politique française rien ne va plus
entre le pc et le ps il s'agit bien sûr
de la préparation des municipales il ya
une semaine pierre mauroy et georges
marchais était tout sourire après la
signature d'un accord national et bien
ce soir on est au bord de la rupture
il ya déjà eu la sphère des têtes de
liste à paris ce soir les communistes
sont bien près de claquer la porte
pascal guimier il est des poignées de
mains qui peuvent cacher des malentendus
et des mariages de raison connaître de
légères turbulences en glissant dans
leur corbeille un accord national en
bonne et due forme le couple pc ps
croyait avoir fait le plus dur mais
c'était compter sans leur base
le pacte de non-agression signé à paris
n'empêche pas ici ou là des dérapages
qui font plutôt mauvais effet à deux
mois des municipales
en fait tout est question
d'interprétation pc et ps chose des
lunettes différentes pour lire un seul
et même texte
côté socialiste pas question de
reconduire purement et simplement les
accords de 83 ans 6 ans le rapport de
force a changé
faux rétorque que des communistes nous
restons attachés à l'union quoiqu'en
pense pierre membres il n'a pas besoin
de s'écarter de cet accord ni
d'envisager des primaires ni de brandir
des menaces en tout cas nous ne faisons
pas et à partir de là les choses
devraient se réduire voire disparaître
dialogue de sourds donc autour d'une
trentaine de villes georges marchais
s'irrite pierre mauroy s'énerve
les socialistes ont décidé de repousser
d'une semaine leur convention pour
arrêter la composition définitive de
leur liste en clair sept jours phase
inclus pour permettre aux pc de revenir
à de meilleurs sentiments
le bras de fer heureusement l'accord
signé jeudi dernier n'aura donc
peut-être vécu que ce que vivent les
roses et pendant ce temps là d'autres
scrutins se prépare le prochain et pas
le moins intéressant c'est celui de
marseille dimanche une partie de
marseille vote pour élire l'un de ses
députés
il s'agit d'une des dernières
législatives invalidé et un nouveau
match bernard tapie à gauche dit et si à
droite c'est le dernier ce dernier guy
teissier qui l'avait emporté au
printemps dernier mais son élection
avait été en effet invalidé pour fraude
deuxième round donc dimanche mais les
marseillais sont apparemment moins
passionné échos de la campagne
patrice blais
l'icd à schaffen charles trenet en
concert pas seulement politique
spectacle aussi bernard tapie bat la
campagne en musique devant un parterre
de plus de 60 ans avec une promesse
s'occuper de l'avenir de leurs enfants
et petits enfants
une campagne plus posée qu'en juin
dernier dans un contexte différent les
municipales approchent pas le même enjeu
national
pour bernard tapie cette élection sera
plus un choix d'hommes qu'un choix
politiques
on sent que les gens davantage envie de
connaître qu'on peut apporter pour
marseille ponctuellement et donc ils ont
un jugement qu'est plus en relation avec
le candidat lui-même qu'avec ses idées
qu'il véhicule
or ce qui dit je suis de proximité c'est
pas parce qu'il sert des mains qui sont
proximité parce qu'ils bougent pas
qu'ils font rien et que sur le plan du
bilan on s'aperçoit qu'ils font pas plus
à l'échelle nationale que sur le plan du
local sur le terrain de la campagne guy
teissier lui a reçu en charles pasqua un
renfort de qualité
le champion de l'union de l'opposition
comptent avant tout sur son implantation
municipal il est maire de
l'arrondissement depuis 83 candidats de
proximité
il cultive sa popularité pour lui
bernard tapie n'est qu'une pièce
rapportée ce qu'ils vont sautillant
d'une caméra un poste disant que le
travail de députés ne consisterait qui a
légiféré
c'est du pipeau c'est du vent le front
national vous a demandé de choisir de
donner vraiment une réponse accord par
accord avant le premier tour rien ne
presse se regarder il est 5 heures le
temps est beau on fait campagne pourquoi
voulez vous que je me précipite on
pouvait faire un accord avec lui
éventuellement car les 22% du front
national en juin dernier pèseront lourd
dans les urnes dimanche
sans accord ronald perdomo menace de se
maintenir au second tour s'il obtient
plus de 12 % des inscrits menace
identique de la part des communistes
annie gweth s'affirme seule candidate de
gauche totalement opposés à un report de
ses voix sur bernard tapie négociation
difficile en perspective entre les deux
tours éducation suite la concertation
continue et va se poursuivre entre le
ministre et tous les représentants de
l'enseignement en discussion vous le
savez les rythmes de travail des élèves
les journées trop longues aussi le trop
grand nombre de redoublements ou encore
le salaire des profs en france est sûre
il ya beaucoup à faire mais comment ça
se passe à l'étranger bien voici ce soir
l'exemple de l'allemagne expliqué par
notre correspondant à bonn philippe
rochot
les accès sont libres libres parce
qu'aujourd'hui à hambourg c'est la grève
des professeurs
un événement rare en allemagne fédérale
où la grève est interdite aux
fonctionnaires qui sont sanctionnés pour
cela le droit de grève est d'ailleurs
l'une des revendications du syndicat gew
et de l'éducation nationale on se battra
toujours pour le droit de grève afin
d'arriver à notre but est le but c'est
la réduction du temps de travail pour
les professeurs dans un système où
l'élève est libre dès le début de
l'après midi
d'après mes expériences élèves allemands
en plus le sens de la responsabilité et
apprennent plutôt que les jeunes
français à travailler seul à travailler
chez eux ce qui est osée causés par le
rythme scolaire qui est très différent
en année les élèves normalement ou en
cours que le matin pendant que les
jeunes français on court aussi l'après
midi ils ont il reste peu de temps pour
faire leurs devoirs chez eux ici les
heures de cours ne font que 45 minutes
trente élèves par classe une formation
professionnelle dès l'âge de 15 ans un
système dont les allemands se vante mais
que la centrale syndicale ig élevé
remettent en question de reproches de
long 6 heures de 45 minutes ne sont pas
assez intensive pour apprendre une
matière
les élèves sont toujours en train de
changer il faudrait travailler plusieurs
heures par jour la même matière
seuls quelques centres d'essais le font
déjà le peu de revendications salariales
pour les enseignants allemands mieux
payés que les français mais en demandant
une réduction du temps de travail comme
les fonctionnaires qui ont obtenu cette
année et 38 heures et demie par semaine
les syndicats veulent aussi enrayé un
chômage qui touche 80 mille instituteurs
et professeurs réunion du g7 vendredi 3
février le g77 technique mais il s'agit
en fait des ministres des finances des
sept pays les plus riches ils se
retrouveront à washington le 3 février
donc ça nous amène à l'économie c'est
donc à la sphère pesci n'est une
nouvelle fois la cob la commission des
opérations de bourse termine son travail
sur cette affaire de
fraude elle a entendu le financier samir
traboulsi et sans doute d'autres
protagonistes importants chaque jour
l'étau se resserre un petit peu plus la
piste suisse notamment se confirme par
le biais de la société soco finances
françoise joly c'est au bout de ce
couloir derrière cette porte fermée
qu'on a effectué l'essentiel des ordres
litigieux soko finances a acheté 88
mille actions de la société triangle
propriétaires d'american cannes dès le
début des négociations théoriquement
secrètes entre pechiney et les
américains ce qu finances affirme
n'avoir été qu'un intermédiaire n'avoir
qu'exécuter des ordres venus d'ailleurs
mais fait troublant cet ailleurs été
très bien informés trop bien informé
pour preuve la ruée sur les titres
triangle et c'est aux caraïbes plus
précisément dans l'île d'anguilla
véritable paradis fiscal que se trouve
la société qui a passé un tiers de ses
ordres d'achat l'international 10 quand
bank
ici le secret bancaire est seul maître à
bord international discount bank affirme
avoir agi pour le compte d'un client un
client qu'il sera donc très difficile à
identifier
bonjour est ce que je pourrais parler au
directeur de la société sil vous plait
bonjour est ce bien vous qui avait
acheté n'est qu'à trois mille actions de
prénoms comme le disent les autorités
américaines
je n'ai aucun commentaire à faire sur
cette chose mais une chose est sûre le
client de cette société fait partie du
petit nombre de gens au courant du
déroulement précis des négociations une
vingtaine de personnes au plus parmi
elles quelques hauts responsables de
pechiney du ministère de l'économie et
des finances de la société américaine
triangle et des intermédiaires comme
l'homme d'affaires samir traboulsi qui
ce soir affirme
janvier demain 17 janvier et je leur ai
vu tout ce que je savais c'est à faire
c'est quelqu'un doit savoir ce que je
pense
les enquêteurs américains et français
ont donc pour tâche d'identifier cet
informateur qui a également permis à
deux industriels français est un homme
d'affaires américano suisse d'empêcher
de confortables bénéfices tout à l'heure
le ministre de l'économie pierre
bérégovoy présenté ses voeux à la presse
il est resté dans le vague sur cette
affaire et ce soir il a de nouveau parlé
de cette affaire pechiney philippe
sassier il a encore soutenu son
directeur de cabinet alain boublil oui
tout à fait fermement il l'a soutenu en
lisant qui lui donnerait les
possibilités les moyens de défendre son
honneur et tout à l'heure devant les
journalistes économiques et financiers
dont vous avez fait partie hervé et bien
il a dit que alain boublil été
injustement attaqué monsieur pierre
bérégovoy a répété qu'il voulait que la
cob le gendarme de la bourse agissent
avec célérité et qu' ils prennent elles
puissent se faire prendre des sanctions
il a dit que la cob donnerait les
conclusions de son enquête à la fin du
mois et il s'est engagé publiquement à
ce que la vérité sorte qu'il y à un
sondage que vous évoquerez je crois tout
à l'heure sur lesquels et les français
se demandent si on veut connaître un
jour la vérité en tout cas le ministre
n'a pas confirmé une rumeur qui courait
dans paris cet après-midi selon laquelle
alain boublil pourrait démissionner il
n'a pas non plus répondu à la question
d'un de nos confrères qui lui demandait
comment allez vous sortir de cette
mauvaise situation parce que s'il y a
dans ces rumeurs beaucoup de calomnies
beaucoup de choses fausses
et bien ce cas ce qui est vrai c'est que
le cabinet du ministre de l'économie a
beaucoup de peine à fonctionner les un
petit peu traumatisé par toutes ces
affaires par toutes ces rumeurs de mal
que toute l'administration des finances
est également traumatisé à preuve par
exemple c'est que tout à l'heure lors
des voeux du ministre vient les grands
directeurs celui de budget celui de la
fiscalité celui du commerce extérieur
n'était pas la tombe où le malaise il
était et je dirais là palpable un climat
qui n'est pas bon donc philippe et cela
entraîne de nouvelles rumeurs politique
cette fois complète alors oui dans les
rumeurs il y en a une c'est celle d'un
la réaménagement ministériel possible
après les municipales peau pour tenir
compte de certains événements qui se
sont passés ces jours derniers certains
dit
même que roger fauroux le ministre de
l'industrie a lancé c'est énorme pavé
dans la marre bien pourrait-il et c'est
son poste car malgré tous les démentis
officiels qui concerne la société
générale malgré que monsieur pierre
bérégovoy affirme que tout est clair et
bien dans beaucoup de milieux financiers
ont dit que la grosse affaire c'est la
société générale que c'est beaucoup plus
grave que pechiney voilà où l'on en est
ce soir
merci philippe nous aurons l'occasion
d'y revenir en tout cas michel rocard le
premier ministre était par aurillac
aujourd'hui bien sûr les journalistes
qui l'accompagnent et n'ont pas manqué
de lui poser une question sur ces
affaires qui empoisonnent la vie
politique
michel rocard a réaffirmé son soutien à
son ministre de l'économie
écoutez j'ai pas de voir les autorités
en charge terminé leurs travaux et les
rendre publics ou les transmettre à la
justice s'il ya lieu
confiant que je suis de ce que leurs
conclusions font apparaître que les
pouvoirs publics français ne sont pas le
moins du monde en bosses deuxième mot
sur ce sujet sera pour dire qu'à mes
yeux on vieillit bien virer gauvois et
d'une compétence d'une loyauté et d'une
intégrité totale ont toujours
aujourd'hui on essaye de profiter d'une
situation pose pour terreau atteinte à
son autorité
je dis moi qui avais eu lieu sous
l'autorité et entière je tenais à le
dire
reste à propos de cette affaire un
sondage dont parlait finit pas l'instant
un sondage ifop publié par l'express 80
% des français estiment que toute la
vérité ne sera pas faite sur cette
affaire
les français en particulier ne font pas
confiance aux hommes politiques pour
faire éclater la vérité
jean-michel mercurol pechiney société
générale des affaires graves pour les
français qui pensent à 80% que toute la
vérité ne sera pas faite pour deux tiers
des sondés ces affaires affaiblissent
l'image des hommes politiques et 48 %
jugent qu'elles affaiblissent le parti
socialiste dans le hit parade de la
confiance pour faire éclater la vérité
la presse vient en tête avec 59 %
françois mitterrand n'est crédité lui
que de 50% de confiance devant michel
rocard 47%
quant au ministre des finances peer
berrer
beauvois 54% des sondés ne lui font pas
confiance pour révéler la vérité la
moitié des français jugent l'affairisme
dans la vie politique tout aussi
important aujourd'hui qui hier mais 35%
estiment qu'il est plus important encore
aujourd'hui et peut-être une autre
affaire de délit d'initié elle
concernerait cette fois le groupe lvmh
moët hennessy louis vuitton un délit qui
serait intervenu lors de l'annoncé des
bons résultats de cette société une fois
encore des personnes au courant en
auraient profité avant les autres en
pologne le trouble suscité par
l'éventuelle légalisation du syndicat
solidarité
d'un côté il y à solidarnosc qui est
très sceptique mais de l'autre le parti
communiste polonais lui est très secoué
par cette affaire jérôme ni l'ouverture
que nous faisons devrait entraîner dans
les prochains mois un bouleversement du
paysage social et politique explique le
général jaruzelski lors d'une conférence
de presse cet après midi il a pris le
pouvoir fin 80 pour éliminer solidarité
de la scène politique polonaise
sept ans après il est contraint de
mettre une menace de démission dans la
balance pour lancer un processus qui
pourrait aboutir à la re légalisation
sous certaines conditions du syndicat 10
ou un long chemin parcouru avec
aujourd'hui un revirement complet
difficile à opérer sur le général
jaruzelski
c'est à l'arraché qu'il a réussi à faire
accepter au comité central du parti
communiste
le principe du pluralisme politique et
syndicale avec à la clé la
reconnaissance de solidarité face à
l'hostilité de nombreux membres du parti
notamment du président du syndicat
officiel
jalouse elle ce qui a dû recourir à une
motion de confiance procédure
exceptionnelle à varsovie
c'est une victoire pour les valises à la
re l'égalisation de solidarité a été au
coeur des grands conflits sociaux de
l'été dernier mais dès cet après midi
l'électricien de gdansk fait part à la
presse de ses réserves
beaucoup dorment au mais tout reste à
négocier il faut s'organiser
affirme-t-il prévoyant des réactions de
la base dès lundi
il sait que le premier ministre propose
comme préalable à la reconnaissance de
solidarité des conditions inacceptables
comme le renoncement à la grève pour une
période de deux ans françois mitterrand
bulgarie deuxième journée de sa visite
officielle fidèle à son habitude le chef
de l'état français a rencontré des
personnalités hors de la vie politique
aujourd'hui en bulgarie il a dialogué
d'abord avec les intellectuels ensuite
avec les étudiants georges bortoli à
sofia monsieur mitterrand a été fait
aujourd'hui docteur honoris causa de
l'université de sofia avant de
s'adresser aux étudiants dialogue pas
toujours très conformiste par exemple la
question faut-il garder les dirigeants
âgés viser clairement pour les jeunes
bulgares l'inamovible todor jivkov mais
monsieur mitterrand quoi qu'il soit
largement le cadet du président bulgare
a pris courtoisement la question pour
lui il est certain qu'il bon que
parviennent aux responsabilités des
hommes appartenant à des générations
durant dans la force de l'âge
mais s'il y en a pas
moi je suis je suis né dans une région
de vignes vignes et tous les produits de
la vie on dit qu'il s'améliore en
vieillissant
tel est mon ambition
monsieur et madame mitterrand ont
retrouvé ce soir monsieur jivkov on
recevoir le pas est le seul de
l'hospitalité dans la ville de plovdiv
avant de regagner paris
au proche orient les territoires occupés
par israël
un palestinien tué et 27 autres blessés
ce jeudi par les tirs des soldats
dufrègne un bilan malheureusement
quotidien qui porte à 350 morts en 13
mois le bilan total de cette guerre des
pierres
le principe du pluralisme politique et
syndicale avec à la clé la
reconnaissance de solidarité face à
l'hostilité de nombreux membres du parti
notamment du président du syndicat
officiel
j'arrose health qui a dû recourir à une
motion de confiance procédure
exceptionnelle à varsovie
c'est une victoire pour lech walesa
l'art l'égalisation de solidarité a été
au coeur des grands conflits sociaux de
l'été dernier mais dès cet après midi
l'électricien de gdansk fait part à la
presse de ses réserves
beaucoup d'eau mots mais tout reste à
négocier il faut s'organiser
affirme-t-il prévoyant des réactions de
la base
dès lundi il sait que le premier
ministre propose comme préalable à la
reconnaissance de solidarité des
conditions inacceptables comme le
renoncement à la grève pour une période
de deux ans françois mitterrand bulgarie
deuxième journée de sa visite officielle
à fidèle à son habitude le chef de
l'état français a rencontré des
personnalités hors de la vie politique
aujourd'hui en bulgarie il a dialogué
d'abord avec les intellectuels ensuite
avec les étudiants georges bortoli à
sofia monsieur mitterrand a été fait
aujourd'hui docteur honoris causa de
l'université de sofia avant de
s'adresser aux étudiants
dialogue pas toujours très conformiste
par exemple la question faut-il garder
les dirigeants âgés visait clairement
pour les jeunes bulgares l'inamovible
toit d'or jivkov mais monsieur
mitterrand quoi qu'il soit largement le
cadet du président bulgare a pris
courtoisement la question pour lui il
est certain qu'il bon que parviennent
aux responsabilités des hommes
appartenant à des générations
disons de la force de l'âge mais s'il y
en a pas moi je suis je suis né dans une
région de vignes the bean et tous les
produits de la vie on dit qu'il
s'améliore en vieillissant
tel est mon ambition
monsieur et madame mitterrand ont
retrouvé ce soir monsieur jivkov pour
recevoir le pas est le seul de
l'hospitalité dans la ville de plovdiv
avant de regagner paris
au proche orient les territoires occupés
par israël
un palestinien tué 27 autres blessés ce
jeudi par les tirs des soldats
israéliens
un bilan malheureusement quotidien qui
porte à 350 morts en 13 mois le bilan
total de cette guerre des pierres
parmi ces victimes de très nombreux
jeunes des enfants souvent est de
nouveau la polémique en israël un énorme
malaise
la honte de beaucoup pour cette guerre
sale par exemple le compositeur dan
almagor un homme très connu en israël
n'hésite pas à protester publiquement
martine laroche joubert propagent les
grands dit le militaire israélien
paroles et musique c'est lui dan almagor
auteurs compositeurs célèbres exclu
depuis quinze jours ça s'éduque hâtif de
l'armée parce qu'une lacune en plus d'
assassiner des enfants palestiniens
l'hôpital palestiniens de jérusalem est
où l'on soigne les blessés les plus
graves du soulèvement de l'intifada la
plupart sont des adolescents la présence
à leur chevet de dan almagor celle
d'anne isralien qui n'acceptent plus ce
matin l'armée vient de publier le bilan
du mois 30 morts 500 blessés comme celui
ci atteint d'une balle en caoutchouc
seront marqués à vie c'est comme un
cauchemar mais ça ne veut rien dire il
n'y a aucune raison pour qu'il y ait
autant de morts causés le soldat de mon
peuple de mes frères et demi oui ça ne
veut rien dire et c'est pour ça que je
suis si choqué je sais que beaucoup
d'autres vont mourir et qu'après il y
aura la paix les canes état palestinien
naîtra du bon
regardez les ils ont 15 ans 16 ans 12
ans comme celui que nous venons de voir
non je n'arrive pas à croire que mon
peuple tu des enfants de cet âge qui
lancent des pierres parce qu'ils veulent
la liberté à voir le recueil de leur
patrie avec un drapeau exactement ce que
je faisais quand j'avais la rage contre
les anglais pour dan almagor en effet le
combat des palestiniens lui rappelle le
sien contre l'occupation britannique
avant 1948 mais il ne tuez pas les
enfants répètent ils encore au fera du
jem blessés je croyais qu'il va survivre
malgré la souffrance et la révolte d'un
almagor entend aussi des mots qui
ressemble au sien
oui nous ressentons la même chose pour
nous que pour les israéliens
vraiment quand nous voyons dans les
journaux que des amis israéliens sont
blessés nous avons mal pour vous comme
pour notre peuple
ça c'est mon message dénoncer certains
comportements de l'armée
visité des hôpitaux d'almagor et c'est
maintenant de faire encore plus de 80 de
convaincre pas facile face à des
israéliens qui votent à droite les
persuader que des palestiniens aussi
veulent la paix qu'il vaut mieux leur
donner un état que de continuer cette
guerre c'est son message à lyon ils sont
peu nombreux à partager ses idées et
même pour les autres le temps des
questions semblent bien là la coupole
alors de la politique l'académie
française recevait en son saint michel
debré l'ancien premier ministre a fait
l'éloge de son prédécesseur bien sûr
louis de breuil et le nouvel académicien
michel debré n'a pas hésité à réaffirmer
ses convictions personnelles
au cours de sa réception gérard dalmaz
attention baron d'entre les barons du
gaullisme
michel debré 77 ans enfin prêt pour la
postérité des 40 perd du cac antilles il
ne manque plus un bouton de guêtre
uniforme et complet le nouvel homme vers
adore la biche et il a bien failli faire
sa carrière dans le roman quand je
revois mes rêves de jeunesse je me vois
écrivain auteur de théâtre mais les
circonstances ont été ce qu'elles ont
été c'est à dire le déclin de la france
et quiconque a vu
a suivi la guerre l'occupation n'a pas
pu ne pas mettre toutes ses forces au
service du redressement national
et maintenant c'est vrai tous qui a
touch la force et la santé de la patrie
et m'inquiète et m'angoisse à ce poids
là le coeur battant michel debré réalise
un vieux rêve en succédant aux
physiciens louis de brogues le maître de
la mécanique ondulatoire neige bien
descendue
oui car cet auteur de la constitution ce
collectionneur de titre de ministre et
d'honneur en connaît un bout sur les
sciences solennelle michel debré été
reçus chez ses gardiens de la
francophonie autant pour son image
politique que pour ses 25 ouvrages non
moins politique que devient la règle de
droit
quand les traités sont bafoués ou dévoyé
par des états qui ne se considèrent pas
comme liés par leur signature
que devient l'affirmation la dignité de
la personne
devant la montée du racisme dans le
monde où l'évocation d'une guerre st
voilà qui nous contraint en occident à
plus de modestie
nous devons parler de civilisation au
pluriel et avec un petit c il y a déjà
un mot que michel debré voudrait bien
voir redéfinir y compris par les
immortels c'est son mot préféré patrie
d'autres informations en bref elles sont
toutes sportive ce soir échec succès en
images en couleur
jean ma mère
toujours pour carole merle a confirmé
aujourd'hui dans la descente de tignes
sa bonne forme actuelle deuxième à 41
centièmes du vainqueur
la suissesse maria walliser sur une
piste dure et techniques carole merle a
démontré qu'elle est la bonne santé du
ski féminin elle remplit elle seule
palmarès de ce début de saison
merle a trouvé le bon ton
l'homme surprise du jour c'est ramesh
krishnan le joueur indien numéro 51
mondial s'est offert un beau cadeau en
éliminant aujourd'hui les internationaux
d'australie le numéro un mondial le
suédois mats wilander
krishnan dont les seules bonnes
prestations ont lieu une fois lente sur
le gazon de wimbledon a surpris et ses
surprises
il a possédé mats wilander à son propre
jeu celui du fond de court
et pour une fois le marathonien mats
wilander a dû s'incliner
battu sur la condition physique ils ont
cru finale mais vraiment pas un exemple
type
rené arnaud guy ligier tout sourire et
olivier brouillard c'est lui qui a gagné
le gros lot olivier brouillard vainqueur
de deux grands prix en formule 3000 fait
donc son entrée en formule 1 et dans une
écurie française
ligier un vieux rêve réalisé reste
maintenant à le concrétiser
définitivement sur la piste tout au long
de la saison
et j'ajoute les résultats du tiercé
quarté + nous allons les voir
l'ordre d'arrivée pour aujourd'hui
c'était le 11 le 13 le 15000 490 francs
dans un ordre différent 2 198 francs
pour le quarté vous ajoutez le 18 ça
fait entre 11 13 15 18 et vous lisez
vous même les rapports sur l'écran voit
la fin de cette édition du journal tout
de suite la météo avec laurent cabrol
dernière édition du journal ce sera aux
alentours de minuit henri sannier et
puis télématin c'est le premier journal
de la journée à 7 heures avec marc
hautement et catherine ceylac bonne
soirée sur antenne 2 à demain soir 20h